- Notre gouvernement
annonce la mise en place
d'une commission d'enquête.
- France Charbonneau a accepté
de présider cette commission
sans aucune hésitation,
mais elle a demandé
l'appui de sa famille.
FRANCE CHARBONNEAU, juge
de la Cour Supérieure du Qc
- Ensuite, je me suis assurée
d'avoir la collaboration
de deux enquêteurs d'expérience
et qui étaient spécialisés
en matière de crime organisé
parce que les différents volets
de notre mandat commandaient ça.
- Au total, plus de
140 personnes dont une vingtaine
d'enquêteurs, surtout des
policiers, et autant d'avocats,
comptables, analystes,
ingénieurs se sont activés dans
l'ombre, plus de six mois avant
le début des audiences
publiques.
- La preuve est claire,
on a des aveux
du vice-président.
- Dès le début des audiences,
la stratégie des procureurs
est claire.
- Ce que vous dites,
c'est dans le but d'obtenir
des contrats de nature
professionnelle.
- Après.
- Provoquer des révélations
en cascade de la part
des entrepreneurs.
- Ce montant-là allait
aux partis politique.
- C'est sûr que ceux
qui ont ouvert la voie
ont été déterminants.
Et je pense plus
particulièrement à l'ingénieur
Michel Lalonde...
- Je pense qu'au-delà des
rumeurs, on le constatait.
- ... qui a expliqué
la collusion au sein
des firmes d'ingénieurs.
Vous avez aussi Lino Zambito,
qui a expliqué la collusion
et la corruption.
Donc ce que vous dites,
c'est qu'à tous les échelons des
employés de la Ville, il y avait
des gens qui étaient corrompus?
- Absolument.
- Vous avez aussi
Bernard Trépanier avec
sa célèbre phrase...
- Un chum, c'est un chum...
- ... qui marquait vraiment
c'était quoi, la culture
du boys club.
- À la Ville de Montréal.
- À la Ville de Montréal
et le favoritisme
dans l'octroi de contrats...
Et puis vous avez aussi
une phrase marquante, moi,
qui m'a marquée, qui est
celle de Nicolo Milioto.
- Vous me respectez, je vous
respecte. Vous me maltraitez,
je peux vous maltraiter
de la même façon.
- ...Alors ça, c'était à donner
froid dans le dos.
- Les retombées financières
de la commission sont énormes,
aux dires de la présidente.
- La commission a coûté
exactement 44 millions.
Mais si vous comptez qu'un
des impacts les plus importants
a été la baisse des coûts
de construction dans
les contrats publics de 30 %,
juste ça, ça représente
plusieurs milliards de dollars.
- Je veux pas parler
pour Montréal...
- Après la Commission
Charbonneau, Simon Tremblay est
devenu le directeur des services
juridiques de la Ville de Laval.
SIMON TREMBLAY, dg Affaires
juridiques, Ville de Laval
- Les sommes à ce jour,
parce qu'il y a plusieurs
poursuites pendantes encore,
oscillent environ,
selon mon estimé bien imparfait,
à environ 145 millions.
Donc on est déjà, en bon
Québécois, à 100 millions
d'over, dans le vert.
- Les retombées judiciaires
directement engendrées par
la commission sont moins
claires. Est-ce que la juge
Charbonneau aurait souhaité
que plus de responsables de la
corruption soient mis en prison?
- Oui, pour certains procès,
ça a bien été, d'autres,
ça a bien moins été,
mais il faut faire attention à
ne pas se limiter à la vision
punitive de l'exercice.
Notre travail, c'était de
trouver des stratagèmes.
- Quant à moi, vous avez compris
que mon devoir de réserve
m'empêche de répondre
à ces questions-là.
- On peut également penser à
tous les ordres professionnels,
l'Ordre des ingénieurs
qui a été mis sous tutelle,
poursuivi devant
le conseil de discipline,
je pense, près
de 300 ingénieurs.
- Je pense que ça a donné une
prise de conscience collective
de l'étendue et de la nature
de la corruption qui était là
depuis des décennies
puis ça a créé un désir
de mieux faire.
- La présidente ne souhaite pas
revenir sur le coup de théâtre
du commissaire Renaud Lachance
qui avait exprimé sa dissidence
sur les liens entre
le financement des partis
politiques provinciaux et
l'obtention de contrats publics.
- En ce qui concerne
le provincial, les liens étaient
indirects. C'était après avoir
obtenu un certain nombre
de contrats publics, les gens
étaient appelés à passer à la
caisse et c'est dans le rapport.
Et c'est dans ce sens-là que ce
sont des liens indirects.
- Elle ne dira rien non plus
sur sa décision de ne pas
inviter le premier ministre
Jean Charest à témoigner.
Quant à savoir
si la corruption
est maintenant enrayée
au Québec, 10 ans après,
France Charbonneau
et son collègue
ne se font pas d'illusions.
- On espère que les gens qui
nous gouvernent ont compris
le message de tout, à l'époque :
la Commission Charbonneau.
le journalisme d'enquête,
l'effet qu'on appelle l'effet
Marteau, donc l'escouade
Marteau, l'UPAC. L'amalgame
de ça fait une meilleure société
aujourd'hui, je crois.
- Est-ce que ça se continue?
Je ne sais pas, mais c'est sûr
que là où il y a de l'homme,
il y a toujours de l'hommerie.
Mais c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'il faudra toujours rester
vigilant.